d-day the sixth of June today is the
74th anniversary of that day considered
the turning point in world war two
national security correspondent Jennifer
Griffin shows us how it's being
remembered your task will not be an easy
one your enemy is well trained well
equipped and battle-hardened he will
fight savagely we will accept nothing
less than full victory with those words
General Dwight d eisenhower launched the
d-day invasion sending more than 156,000
Allied troops to free France and
eventually Europe of Nazi Germany's grip
many died on the beaches of Normandy as
dawn broke on the shores of France June
6 1944 visitors marked the anniversary
at the American military cemetery above
the beaches some who survived attended a
ceremonial wreath laying at the World
War Two memorial in washington d.c World
War two veteran Herman Zytek stormed you
pop beach at h-hour
on d-day with the Army's 4th Infantry
Division he fought in the Battle of the
Bulge and helped liberate Gow and joined
by alfred petro gallo
who was drafted as he left high school a
member of the 190th field artillery unit
he landed at Omaha Beach on d-day plus
one got out of the boat Lincoln Horner
was just over 19 at the time man the
artillery and entered Gold Beach with
British forces it was important to get
the foothold and from then on it was a
matter of where do we go next at a rose
garden ceremony signing legislation to
help all veterans President Trump
remembered the Greatest Generation more
than 70,000 brave young Americans
charged out of landing craft jumped out
of airplanes and stormed into hell on
the beaches of Normandy saving Western
civilization exactly 74 years ago today
at the Pentagon Jennifer Griffin Fox
News